Fernando I'm going to start with you I
want to ask you this idea about telling
this story visually and the idea of
walls and where they came into the story
and why they were important to you both
cinematically and in terms of the whole
idea of walls and bridges building
bridges through walls and reconciliation
yeah actually the idea of using walls is
like interpretation of the script
because I mean in that speech that Pope
Francis talks about the the the economic
system that is very unfair I think he
was also talking about the wars Pope
Francis has a line that I included in
the film which is built bridges not
walls and actually that's what he does I
mean he's talking to all the religions
he sees the world that's just one one
thing I mean we're all interdependent
one to the other and he sees like this
and he's only one of the few voices that
understands I mean how we depend on each
other and and and so he's the guy that
builds bridges and I've talked I wanted
to include this line so I used the walls
so I could use this his line in the end
Anthony this I believe began as a play
and then became the screenplay is that
right necessary yeah so how did it
develop first it's a play and what
turned it into a movie script I was in
Rome I happened to be in st. Peter's
Square as a tourist and Pope Francis was
by happenstance giving an open-air mass
and he was up there on the super screen
with I guess about 5,000 tourists and I
just became interested in the charisma
of this man but I also knew that there
was a second Pope and he had resigned
that he was sequestered in a convent
about a hundred yards behind and the
question started to arise why would this
first Pope Pope Benedict have resigned
the first to do so in seven hundred
years and I thought there must be a
story there so I
had started with a Google search and
then went back to London and the idea of
a dialog of a real disputation between
them you know a conservative and a
liberal started to take root and in my
mind and I had the lovely experience and
in New York a gentleman came up to me
after the screening and said you do
realize this is a Jewish movie don't you
and I said oh that's interesting what
why do you say that and he said because
it's a foundation aspect of Judaism to
dispute scripture that Dogma is not to
be revered it's to be assailed and
questioned and you basically got two
rabbis going at it here and he said it's
completely Talmud okay and it's it's the
most Jewish film I've ever seen and when
when you're writing a movie about
somebody like Stephen Hawking or Winston
Churchill or Freddie Mercury we know a
little bit about what they've done and
what they've said they've done because
they have friends and family and wives
who've written stories about them popes
aren't quite as public they have sermons
they have things that they say in the
pulpit but they don't really talk about
their inner life so how do you start
piecing together what it is they're
feeling and believing and extrapolating
back from what it is that they're
preaching
yeah well it's interesting I mean
there's vast public records of their
public statements the problem is most of
them are in Latin my Latin is a little
rusty that said took a quid pro quo do
you know that one I believe it's this
for that and we're all learning but no
it's the the first challenge when you're
doing anything based on historical
recorders is is research because it's
you're in effect painting a portrait and
you have to do a good rendering as much
as truthfully as possible to make it
lifelike so that begins with research so
an enormous amount of reading and
talking and and people who knew them I
met some people in Germany who knew
Benedict and and you know this YouTube
and Internet avails and all that stuff
so a lot of research to get it right and
let me jump here even the commissar Rex
is
and the fun things real you I mean feels
like a joke but it's not a joke no they
must research that's what he's talking
you know the most eccentric aspects of
this are absolutely true the venture the
Fanta there's a little Side Story the
Fanta is is because during World War Two
if you were in Nazi Germany they banned
coca-cola but they allowed Fanta
so children at that time became addicted
to this this orange drink and he still
drinks it and doesn't touch a drop of
wine to this day yeah not even
sacramental wine good point we don't
know that's for the sequel the wine
years Tracy I want to ask you about your
work with Fernando you'd worked on
constant gardener and at the time this
project came around I think you were
doing something radically different is
that right well this strange thing is
mark and I were both involved in the
London Olympic opening ceremony I
produced it might designed it and one
occasion Fernando was going to separate
our house in London and we were like you
should do Rios I get no I know a cut to
Fernando directed the opening of the Rio
Olympics so our paths we worked together
on the constant gardener and when
Fernando was sent the script by Jonathan
and Dan for and the Pope as it was then
called it was an amazing opportunity for
us to yeah get back together and get the
old team together as well a lot of the
team from the con cigar nurses are alone
a mock cinematographer
yes sure Wilson multi oscar-nominated
sound recordist yeah many of the team we
got back together mark all avoid the
joke rome wasn't built in a day but how
long did it take you to actually
recreate the Sistine Chapel and we were
thinking about it's designed there are a
lot of people I was there a year and a
half ago who know pretty much what it
looks like but you also have to create
it so that Fernando and the actors can
work in it so what are the design
challenges and how do you balance that
against the practicalities of what they
need for filming location by the way
it's an amazing Sistine Chapel I think
we would all agree
[Applause]
so said the process started obviously
the the script came we we had this whole
sequence in there was central to the
story there was no avoiding it so we sat
down and talked to some fine scenic
artists and worked our program that was
going to take 17 weeks which would mean
the film would be finished by that time
so then I just think again so we looked
at some versions where we thought about
printing it
we tried that it was very flat and then
and then one of the guys you have a
company in Italy who had just done a new
process and they're called tattoo war
and so basically what they do is they
take a digital image they print it onto
a sheet of film like a children's tattoo
and you wouldn't you know when you put
it on your skin and then you peel it
back so basically it gets all all of the
colour in the ink and then as a
construction team we build a plaster
wall and then they paper it with these
tattoos so we tried this out as a
technique and it was fantastic so that
took four weeks to paper a week to print
four weeks of paper and we took seven
weeks to build all the rest of the
structure which was obviously that the
floor and the and the the Rood screen
and the high altar and all those pieces
it's got a pretty good ceiling how do
you do the ceiling and get lights the
thing was actually we just managed to
get a studio in Cinecitta which is a big
studio in Rome but it was only just big
enough to take the floor plan just and
it wasn't totally enough to take the
ceiling so we made it compromised made
it as high as we possibly could in the
time and the rest was CG for the ceiling
Wow but I will tell you a story that
obviously Fernando and Cesare the
cameraman was super keen when we went
around the Sistine Chapel it's obviously
it's been cleaned and refurbished and
it's super beautiful the colors are
super bright and when we got the
material the digital material that was
on offer it was from the pre cleaned
cysteine so it was full of candle smoke
and it was almost dark and brown and
that's not what he wanted so in the end
what we did was we managed to gather
some scenic artists and we painted a lot
of the stuff of the Sistine Chapel we
painted there
third scales a third of the actual size
by hand we painted it in the right
colors then we photographed that and
then we put that up so it was sort of
partly partly photographic partly scenic
in the end Jonathan I'm going to ask you
about the first day you were able to
step into that set I hope it was mostly
completed by the time you were able to
visit the Sistine Chapel and what that
meant as an actor to walk into that
space well it kind of meant no acting
required it was an extraordinary space
and at first I've never been patient
enough to queue to get into the real
Sistine Chapel so this was a this was a
great opportunity for me to see it thank
you Mark
there are tours if you like sign up
early you can go ahead of time but I
don't need to know okay I'm going to ask
you about it's kind of an iteration the
question I asked Anthony about getting
to the interior life of the Pope because
when you're building that character do
you start by looking at how he appears
on video there's lots of YouTube videos
you read his writings how do you start
to inhabit the mind the physical part
will ask about later but the mind of the
Pope well obviously you start with the
script and all the a lot of the
information about what he thinks and
feels about things about religion and
the church and politics is is all there
in the script so what you need to do in
some ways is to embody him physically
and for me I was you know it wasn't that
much of a stretch because the day he was
created Pope the internet was full of
images of him and me and something me as
me and some as me as the high Sparrow
and they everyone was seeing the
likeness to the extent that one of my
son's called and said that are you the
Pope you know I was on I got a good
start with the facial likeness but yeah
I did I did what you said I mean lots of
contemporary actors they were
you look you go to youtube when you look
at images of of the man the way he walks
the way he talks which is very important
to me and even though he spoke with a
Spanish accent
the sort of the cadences and the the
calmness and the gentleness with which
he can say the most powerful things and
there was the greatest help to me as an
actor I think was because when you're
playing these people who are ultimately
quite powerful you don't want to start
with that's not where you start what
you'd look for that person's flaws and
their weaknesses and you that that have
driven them to become that person and
there's particular footage that I looked
at when he was when he was still
Cardinal Archbishop in in Bono Cyrus and
he was seen then and is still seen as a
very divisive character because of his
possible collaboration with the junta
and there's as a film of him being
interrogated by his peers by fellow
Cardinals about this situation and he
looks very grim and very angry
that he's sitting there and he's bless
you you see comes naturally so that it's
very important because you see him
impatient and angry and grim and one of
the people who helped me enormously and
helped the film was a Jesuit priest in
Bowness Harris who was advising as about
the ritual of the church and everything
else and about how to say mass and
whether the chalices were in the right
place and all that stuff but I got to
speak with him about Magog Leo and I
asked him about the man and he said that
he worked under him and he didn't like
him and lots of his fellow priests
didn't like him because of this this
this period in his life and there and
the Colonel's and he said that he was a
very authoritarian figure very strict
and when he was created Pope and he was
on the balcony and they were watching in
bronze eras on television they said we
we didn't recognize him because he was
smiling and he said we knew him in buona
sera system man who never smile and
that's really you know really
interesting a character note and it it
shows that the journey that he's been on
when you say building a character it's
he's he's built by character and what
you follow it you follow those stages
and it is that there's some Drive and
when you see him now and post being made
the Pope he's this kind of liberated
figure I think who's it's interesting to
note that he's never been back to
Argentina he's been to other Latin
American countries but what's holding
him back from going back to Argentina I
don't know but maybe they'll send me
instead thank you all for coming out
thank you